based on her behavior and the behavior
you talk about in the book it's just
incredible she was spying on her own
employees at one point you say in the
book that she had her IT director find
out that one of her lieutenants had
looked at porn on their laptop and then
used that as an excuse to fireman
essentially blackmail them out of their
stock options right that happened I mean
he had actually tried to call her on the
fact that they were doing bogus demos
and after eight months at the company he
was chief financial officer he was
aghast because he thought that demos
were real and he'd been bringing around
these investors you know and they were
certainly under the impression - that
the demos were real and so he confronted
her in her office in November 2006 so
this is just a couple years into the
life of the company and and said to her
Elizabeth we can't do this anymore you
know it's it's crossing a line it's
going too far and and she turned
ice-cold and said to him you know you're
not a team player and I think you should
leave right now and it was very clear
from a demeanor and her tone of voice
that she meant not just leave her office
but leave the company and he had been
fired and what then happened is a couple
days later the the IT guy the head of IT
had was going through his laptop and and
because they were so paranoid about
information leaking out they would take
you know laptops back and phones back
and then they would upload everything to
the servers and the process of doing
that came across the fact that the now
fired CFO had browsed porn worth laptop
which you know it's probably not
something you should do but the IT guy
didn't think it was you know something
worthy of capital punishment either and
he unfortunately told Elizabeth about it
and she then used it to to claim that
that's why he was fired and to deny him
stock options and this is a 20 to 22
year old woman at this point so at a
very young age she has learned to be
incredibly ruthless and manipulative and
she seemed to get people to buy into her
being the next Steve Jobs had she had
some sort of obsession with Steve Jobs
that you sort of outlined in the book
she hired a bunch of Apple employees
early on
right she would wear the turtleneck and
how much now that cuz you're an outside
here from Brooklyn like me you're not
like part of this thing out here how
much of this is that she pattern matched
or that she checked a checked boxes that
made people want to believe that this
was the female Steve Jobs I mean that
there was a lot of that going on and it
was encouraged it was actually actively
encouraged by these older men who were
in her entourage
you know Channing Robertson was her
engineering professor at Stanford and
supported her when she dropped out and
joined her board and it accompanied her
on pitches to VC companies and he was
quoted in some early stories in the tech
press one was in Inc and other one was
in red herring and one of them and this
is going back in early 2006 he already
is comparing her to Steve Jobs and to
Bill Gates Wow
Don Lucas whom she's venture capital
right who groomed Larry Ellison helped
him take Oracle public in the mid-80s he
became chairman of Theron is's Board for
a while and and invested money and
convinced Larry Ellison tenth chief
enabler yeah I mean really certainly I
think he was the record pretty much
shows that he was manipulated to yeah to
some extent but he helped her with his
network of contacts and helped her gain
credibility and so yeah you had these
these older men around her that she that
she manipulated